WILDCARD SPOT.
A COUPLE OF
RETRIEVE HIS OWN PASS.
NO ONE WAS HOME.
NOW, REVERSES IT TO SUSTR, HELD
IN
WRIST CHOP COME  YAAKOV
FOR THIS. T
WITH THE NUMBER ONE GUY.
.
MOMENT AGO, AND
AT THE OTHER END OF THE ICE,, F
POWER PLAY GOAL. DUCHENE
IS OPEN ON THE BACK DOOR.
HE WAS TRYING EVERYTHING HE
COULD TOTO SCORES A POWER-PLAY
AND THE IMPACT THIS
SCORE.
JUST LIKE THAT.
2-0, NASHVILLE. AFTER REVIEW, T
PLATE WAS OFFSIDE.
WE HAVE
TURNAROUND.
GOT A LOT ON IT.
GOOD JOB TO GE
>> I THOUGHT INITIALLY THE WAY
THE  HIM.
HE PIVOTS STRARA
>> Brian: HE RECOGNIZED THERE
WAS TRAFFIC OUT  R  TO FILIP FO
WE SAW HERE
JOSI.
HE BRINGS IT ACROSS.
MILANO.
HE GETS
MOVING TOTOBY FOWLER BUT HE RUN
TOWARDS THE NET.
>> Brian: ANOTHER GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE HAD WAITEDb
BACK TO THE POINT.
>> Bob: ANY CONCERN FOR
NASHVILLE AND JOHN HYNED UP BY
SAROS.
THAT WASTHE NET.
IT LOOKS LIKE JUUSE SAROS WAS
ABOUT TO CO
IT TOOK EIGHT WEIRD BOUNCE OFF
THE WALL.
AND  BY COLTON
SISSONS TO PUT THIS AWAY FOR
NASHVILLE.
HE SCORES.
SECOND OF THE NIGHT.